okay so therefore I know for
four people
the maximum number of handshakes
is what again we just said three
so far so good
if we actually went and played this out
right for example uh in this situation A
is done let's let's tally it right one
two three handshakes okay
um so far everyone else has just done
the one is that okay but think more
stuff could happen right like what what
else could happen maybe C and D shake
hands
where are we at at the moment if I do
that
yeah they each have two now okay so so
more things happen right and I suppose
if I if I wanted like actually at this
point all I'm going to do is get more
people towards three handshakes does
that make sense because these guys are
already on two a can't shake hands with
anyone else right so you could have
three handshakes you could have two
handshakes you could have one handshake
so in this situation how many pigeon
holes are there just having a look at
this right
we know three is possible
if three happens how many handshakes do
all the rest of them have let me just
rewind go back to here
at this point if three handshakes happen
for a
everyone's already at one like that's
you there can't be a person who didn't
Shake anyone's hand does that make sense
so therefore the maximum number of
handshakes here is three
the mineral number
of handshakes in this situation
is what
it's one because we just said there was
one person who shook everyone's hand
because they're I don't know a social
overachiever or something right so in
this case have a look right and there's
no such thing as a half handshake is
there in this case I know my pigeons how
many pigeon holes are there
one
or two or three there are three pigeon
holes
do you see what I've just established
four pigeons three pigeon holes by
petition principle has to happen okay
now this is actually there's one other
way for this to happen though because
remember we said like we just kind of
played out what's the maximum number of
handshakes that happens but that's
because a for some reason is just um
Ultra extroverted and they made sure
they got around to everyone okay let's
just like replay the situation again
you've got a b c and d okay and maybe
what you find is
um I don't know
d
they're just um
super covered like aware or something
like that they're like I refuse to shake
hands with anyone okay so now what
happens what's the maximum number of
handshakes in this situation
it's two where'd you get two from
we went back with a being like you know
very extroverted right so they share
cancer they they share Kansas C and then
they're like yeah nah right so they just
kind of like awkwardly elbow bump or
something like that so the maximum here
is two
what's the minimum in this situation
it's zero because of this person who
doesn't want to shake hands with anyone
right so here
the minimum number
is zero okay just like before there's no
half handshakes right so how many pigeon
holes are there in this situation it's
either zero
or one
or two they're still the same three
pigeon holes or the same number of
pigeon holes even though the actual
pigeon holes are different okay so this
is still three pigeon holes
for four people does that make sense and
that's why you can actually see the
numbers right now have a look right I've
got zero and then going back here I've
got
two one and one right like there's
there's no way that B and C can't be you
can keep on doing it right we could go
to five people as you suggested and you
still will not be able to get two people
having a different number
how's your brain feeling at the moment
were you able to follow the argument
um let me just rewind right the real key
for every pigeonhole principle question
is work out what are the pigeons and
what are the pigeon holes right and then
once you know one is going to be larger
than the other that's why you get this
um this pairing happening or at least
pairing okay so I'm just returning back
to that that's the principle and any
question you can throw at me I just want
to identify what has to match up to what
other things so people a number of
handshakes or
um number of friends on Facebook or
sorry that's a really old thing like
whichever shows my age whichever other
thing like number of donuts that they've
eaten right or
um how many cities they've visited in
the world so long as like if I've got
like this is the same reasoning
underneath how I can know that there are
at least two people who have the same
number of hairs on their head in Sydney
yeah
have you heard this before I've heard
that other questions yeah so what they
would say is like the person who's got
the most hair on their head it's
something like 30 000 hairs which
doesn't sound like actually that many
you're like I feel like I've got lots
right it's just the area of your head
and how thick a human hair is right so
30 000 right and obviously there's some
person who has no hairs on their head
right but if you've got thirty thousand
and one people at least two of them will
have the same number right maybe it's
the two bored guys that's fine in fact
Sydney has like over four million people
right so you've got loads and loads of
people who have that same number of hair
pigeons
pigeon holes that's all there is to it
okay
so what we've done is we've just modeled
everything right and what we've got here
is we've established that for these
smaller cases right for n people
there are n minus one
handshakes possible
okay that's what I kind of got to up
here so you said four people three
handshakes possible
um
there this happens when or this occurs
when
the minimum
is one handshake and this is this is
where I've reasoned that right
this is and I can unfortunately one of
the things about this part of mats is it
is a little bit wordy because there
aren't I mean I could give you symbols
to represent all this but actually the
symbols would be worse at least words I
understand right so I can say therefore
one two three dot dot dot to n minus one
is n minus one total
pigeon holes
so by the pigeonhole principle
I would actually write the words pigeon
principle by the way but I'm just trying
to save you guys a bit of time so you'd
have to wait for me right by the
pigeonhole principle uh what have I got
here
um
at least two
of the N people
and in this case like it could be 15 or
it could be four or it could be 700
right it actually doesn't matter
um
will
have the same number of handshakes
sorry that handwriting is so horrendous
but there's the idea right so all you
really need to establish is well you
have to say pigeonhole principle
somewhere it's a bit like mathematical
induction in that way like I've got to
use the phrase and then secondly the key
idea is
um
whether they when I have it pigeons
versus pigeon holes that's it
um that is the pigeonhole principle so
long as one is more than the other
you'll get some pairing somewhere is
that okay
I have two questions
so why when the minimum is one because
you did in the example above the minimum
the zero and you still work yep okay so
then what I would say is like I would
have this this is actually I'm glad you
mentioned it actually this is two
separate cases so this is okay I'd call
this case one and I'd call this case two
in my working right and so no matter
which one I go for like these are the
only two possible things I guess what
I'm trying to do is say how high can
that maximum go that has its own minimum
associated with it and then I say but
can I get any lower than this minimum
and the answer is I can but that minimum
has a different maximum associated with
it so it's either 0 1 and 2. or it's one
two and three but in both cases actually
doesn't matter how many handshakes there
are it matters how many pigeon holes
there are in both cases it's three in
both cases it's fewer than the number of
people or pigeons that I have so so long
as I've got fewer it's okay so I'd
actually
I could write all this again this is
case one I could write all of that again
but with
um
n minus two and zero does that make
sense
that number right there
so this is in that case where we've got
some super anti-social person right if
you've got a super anti-social person
who refuses to shake hands with anyone
so now I know I'm not in case one that's
how I know I'm not in case one because
I've got someone who's got less than one
handshake
when you've got zero handshakes though
we had a look at um this picture right
here the highest this can go is n minus
two
so long as they can shake hands with
everyone that gives you n minus one
handshakes but if there's someone it's
actually like there's not that person in
the situation yeah does that make sense
it's like oh no there's only this number
of people there two but the total
actually is four okay
I know that's a bit tricky it's the it's
the language around it and the fact that
there are cases if it makes you feel any
better A lot of pigeonhole principle
questions actually won't have different
cases they'll just be the one situation
work out how many of these how many of
these you're done okay
um but this was a particularly maybe
this is why this was the example that's
challenging for you to understand okay
um I forgot what was asking actually it
said prove that there will be at least
two people who have made the same number
of handshakes
[Music]
in fact it's kind of a total
um red herring is the technical phrase
like it's just a distraction it doesn't
have to be 15 as we've just demonstrated
it actually could be any number so long
as it's well in fact not even someone is
more than one person they'll have the
same number
situation and I did like what you did
here
without being
okay so um it would be okay as a start
so me doing this was my way of
understanding actually this is what I
wanted to establish right so probably a
better way that I could have done this
is actually to go all the way up to 15
at this point I've established a pattern
and then I can say it's going to be 14
and then one
and then here it would be again for 15
people it would go all the way up to
um
13 to zero so it would be in this case
14 pigeon holes in this case still 14
pigeon holes but I've got 15 people and
that's it okay so um this is in much the
same way as sorry have you guys done you
guys already done series and sequences
right you've done that have you already
you've already met some of it yeah so in
much the same way that when you have to
establish a series right you need say
for example
you need three terms right and then
after that you can say uh to the end
patterns established off I go right but
you can't go like one two to the end
right you actually have to show the
logic that's going on there and the
reason why three is a magic number is
because if I gave you two
this could be arithmetic or it could be
geometric right you're like oh you
really don't know okay and it's the same
thing with this I haven't actually
established a pattern yet until I get to
this point and then I can say oh the
word for this by the way is called
generalizing right and that's why I've
got all these n's and N minus ones here
okay